un rituel constitutionnel d'habitude peu
remarqué mais placée cette année sous
les feux de la rampe
les 538 grands électeurs de 50 états se
sont réunis pour voter en faveur de joe
biden ou de donald trump en reflet du
vote populaire
la californie l'état le plus peuplé des
états unis votre a officiellement pour
le vainqueur du vote populaire de notre
état jeff herbes hayden et sa colistière
la californienne kamala harris sans
grand suspens à la fin de la journée joe
biden et kamala harris ont obtenu 3 106
voix contre 232 pour donald trump et
mike pence
mais au delà de la simple formalité le
collège électoral a été érigé ce lundi
en véritable symbole de la force
démocratique du système politique
américain selon joe biden vous savez
dans la bataille pour l'âme de
l'amérique la démocratie l'emporté nous
le peuple avons voté la foi en nos
institutions a tenu l'intégrité de nos
élections a été préservé maintenant il
est temps de tourner la page
comme nous l'avons fait tout au long de
notre histoire de nous rassembler de
guérir comme je les dis au cours de
cette campagne je serai le président de
tous les américains
donald trump de son côté avait déclaré
qu'il quitterait la maison blanche si
jamais le collège électoral était
favorable à joe biden si le collège
électoral élit le président biden
quitterez-vous la maison blanche
bien sûr que je le ferais mais vous le
savez déjà mais je pense qu il se
passera beaucoup de choses d'ici au 20
janvier beaucoup de choses
une fraude massive a été découverte on
dirait un pays du tiers monde
ces dernières semaines
aucun des recours juridiques de donald
trump visant à contester les résultats
du mois de novembre n'a abouti donald
trump est plus que jamais isolée
son ministre de la justice bulgare a
annoncé sa démission hier il avait
déclaré début décembre n'avoir constaté
aucune fraude à une échelle susceptibles
de changer le résultat électoral
fini donc les recomptages selon
leurs médias américains celui qui est
encore le locataire de la maison blanche
devra enfin assumer son destin électoral
dernière étape à présent l'entrée en
fonction du nouveau président des
etats-unis qui doit intervenir le 20
janvier 2021